President Trump and North Korean
dictator Kim jong-un finished an
unprecedented meeting in Singapore with
a deal to start denuclearizing the
Korean Peninsula we're very proud of
what took place today I think our whole
relationship with North Korea and the
Korean Peninsula is it's going to be a
very much different situation that it
has in the past the two leaders signed
what mr. Trump called a comprehensive
document detailing what he said was
their commitment to establish relations
it offers few specifics on how North
Korea's nuclear arsenal will be removed
the summit which lasted less than five
hours was the first between a sitting US
president and a North Korean leader
president Trump said it would lead to of
many more meetings and he would
absolutely consider he says inviting Kim
to the White House CBS Evening News
anchor Jeff Gore's leading our coverage
from Singapore where the president left
a short time ago Jeff good morning what
a day indeed good morning - good evening
here from Singapore the president said
he did everything he could at this
summit and that's why he is headed back
to the US a little earlier than planned
now while the president and Kim jong-un
here agreed to work toward
denuclearization in exchange for a
security assurances from the US they did
not establish a timetable to meet that
goal could be potentially anywhere from
three to 15 years folks say four D
nuclear denuclearization of the
peninsula if it happens there was also
no mention in the agreement of humans
rights abuses committed by the Kim
regime and no specifics on how the deal
would get done that said there is this
signed document this was the first time
a sitting US president has met with the
leader of North Korea there were these
handshakes major Garrett is on sentosa
island the site of today's historic
summit with more on the president's plan
moving forward major good morning good
morning summit images from this opulent
island hotel were in every way historic
the agreements reached somewhat more
vague and that's important considering
North Korea's checkered history of
living up to agreements made with the
United States he
and so President Trump says there is now
a real chance for peace denuclearization
and a brand new relationship why because
the president said he now trusts Kim
jong-un and knows that he wants to make
a deal more summits appear inevitable
and the president said he's open to
traveling to the North Korean capital of
Pyongyang and inviting Kim to the White
House the letter that were signing is
very comprehensive
president Trump and North Korean leader
Kim jong-un signed a joint statement
seeking a new relationship a process to
bring peace to the two Koreas and for
the North to quote work toward complete
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
mr. president this joint statement does
not talk about verifiable or
irreversible denuclearization yeah is
that a concession on the part of the
United no not at all because if you look
at it I mean it said we are going to
let's say here it will be gone we I
don't think you can be any more plain
than what we're what we're asking we
asked about verifying North Korean
compliance well it's going to be
achieved by having a lot of people there
and as we develop a certain trust and we
think we have done that those people be
Americans or international combinations
of both agencies the combinations of
both and we have talked about it yes the
day began with never-before-seen images
of a sitting American president
repeatedly shaking hands with the leader
of a legendarily repressive and
militarized regime Kim jong-un appeared
to grasp the enormity of the moment
telling the president it was like a
scene from a science-fiction movie
last year's chest-thumping and insults
hurled between the two leaders were a
distant memory replaced by amiable looks
and chats as they walked the colonnade
of one of Singapore's most luxurious
hotels
having them seated alone with
interpreters only Kim told reporters the
two countries had overcome the obstacles
and prejudices of the past later in a
meeting that included the leaders aides
President Trump said he was confident
the two sides would make progress the
president said North Korea possesses a
sizable nuclear arsenal and that Kim
knows as much if not more about it than
the military has supervising it and
despite the fact the North Koreans have
taken no aggressive steps to dismantle
that Arsenal the president said now is
the time to end joint military exercises
u.s. and South Korea the president said
they're expensive and in this atmosphere
of goodwill Jeff he said they are quote
inappropriate